so how do you tell if your object
detection algorithm is working well in
this video you learn about a function
called intersection over a union and as
we use both for evaluating your object
detection algorithm as well as in the
next video using it to add another
component to your object detection
algorithm to make it work even better
let's get started in the object
detection tasks you're expected to
localize the object as well so if that's
the ground truth bounding box and if
your algorithm outputs this bounding box
in purple is this a good outcome or a
bad one so what the intersection / union
function does law iou does is it
computes the intersection / union of
these two bounding boxes so the union of
these two bounding boxes is this area
there's really the area that is you know
contained in either bounding boxes
whereas the intersection is this smaller
region here so what the intersection /
Union does is it computes the size of
the intersection so that orange shaded
area and divided by the size of the
union which is that green shaded area
and by convention that law computer
vision tasks will judge that the answer
is correct if the iou is greater than
0.5 and if the predictor and the ground
truth bounding boxes overlapped
perfectly the iou would be 1 because the
intersection would equal to the union
but in general Selassie IOU is greater
than or equal to 0.5 then you know the
answer
okay you look pretty decent and and by
convention very often 0.5 is used as a
threshold to judge as whether the
predicted bounding box is correct or not
this is just a convention if you want to
be more stringent you can judge an
answer as correct only the IOU is
greater than equal to 0.6 or some other
number but the higher the IOUs the more
accurate the bounding box and so this is
one way to map localization to accuracy
where you just count up the number of
times an algorithm correctly detects and
localizes an object where you could use
the definition like this of whether or
not the object is correctly localized
and again 0.5 is just a human chosen
convention
there's no particularly deep theoretical
reason for it you can also choose some
other fish hole like 0.6 if you want to
be more stringent I sometimes see people
use more stringent criteria like 0.6 or
maybe 0.7 I rarely see people drop the
threshold below 0.5
now we're motivated the definition of
IOU as a way to evaluate whether or not
your object localization algorithm is
accurate or not but more generally IOU
is a measure of the overlap between two
bounding boxes where if you have two
boxes you can compute their intersection
compute a union and take the ratio of
the two areas and so this is also a way
of measuring how similar two boxes are
to each other
and we'll see this used again this way
in the next video when we talk about non
math suppression so that's it for IO you
or intersection over Union not to be
confused with the promissory note
concept an IOU when you're if you lend
someone money they write you a note that
says oh I owe you this much money so
that's also called an IOU it's totally
different concept but maybe it's cool
that you know these two names these two
things have a similar name so now armed
with this definition of IOU
intersection of a Union in the next
video I want to discuss with you
non max oppression which is a tool you
can use to make the outputs of your low
work even better so let's go on to the
next video